SENATORS. GLASER. GLASER
PRESENT. DOLLY. HERE. DOLLY
PRESENT. ASHBY. ASHBY. PRESENT
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. PRESENT.
DODD DODD. PRESENT BARDIYA.
BARDIYA. PRESENT SKINNER. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. GREAT. THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. WE HAVE ONE
BILL TO PRESENT TODAY. IT'S
ASSEMBLY BILL 1878 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. SIR, WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. YOU CAN BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE BILL BEFORE YOU
AND THE RECENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN
REFLECT AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
LEADERSHIP, SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY. THE GOAL OF THE BILL
IS TO OVERCOME OBSTACLES THAT
TRIBAL NATIONS HAVE IN ACCESSING
HOUSING DOLLARS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BUILD OUT
WHAT IS MUCH NEEDED. A HOUSING
SUPPLY FOR THE ENTIRE STATE WITH
A FOCUS ON INDIAN NATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO YOU HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES TO BE HERE?
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO'D
LIKE TO STEP UP AND SAY THEY'RE
IN SUPPORT TO COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. GREAT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM? ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION AND COMMENTS.
MEMBERS, ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? MOVE THE BILL. I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING IT AND
LEADING IT. I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR DONNELLY. THIS IS A Dð
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR. THE
SECRETARY. SAYS THAT THE MEASURE
BE RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONSIDERATION. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR.
GLASER. GLASER I. DONNELLY I
DALY. I ASHBY. ASHBY. I.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I DODD.
DODD. I PADILLA I. PADILLA I.
SKINNER 6 TO 0. THAT HAS SIX
VOTES TO GET OUT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FOR A
MOMENT FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. SO THAT WILL BE IN RECESS.
THANK YOU, MEMBERS, FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. OKAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BRING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON TAX WILL COME OUT
OF RECESS. WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CALL. IT'S A CENTROLEGAL
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1878. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. CURRENT VOTE IS 6
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 7 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT, 7 TO 0. THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY. THIS COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.